i'm on a besoin de tes talents
quelqu'un nous avo lui
qui peut être assez fou pour voler la
firme
je le fais changement de programme ils
ont kidnappé une petite vie temps je la
laisserai pas mourir
sa
personne tu n'es plus sous notre
production des messieurs très méchant
dans nos ateliers il faut qu'on se
mettre à l'abri
salut mon nom je suis grand père
aulas nous
les filles je crois que je vois un
fantôme il nous faut désarmante aura
besoin d'un diagnostic
d'un virginia woolf et d'un agatha
christie
pour le lire
autant te tuer
c'est notre seule chance de mettre
peintre on va leur faire tomber le ciel
sur la tête
je les sers à peu de bruit bon c'est
quoi le plat j'ai commandé albert non
mais tu te fous de moi non
c'est vraiment faesch 1
si jamais race en vivent
je viendrai pas ni ton corps
et une tueuse en série quoi tu tues des
gens non
et tu en as tué plusieurs c'est une
série c'est plus compliqué que ça